DOW GAINED 155.
S&P 500 S&P 500 PICKED UP
S&P 500 S&P 500 PICKED UP.
NASDAQ LOST 8.
TWO NIGHTS MIDTERM ELECTION
PREVIEW TAKES US TO ARIZONA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT ON THE
BALLOT THERE OF COURSE BUT HE IS
A BIG PART OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT A VERY CONTENTIOUS SENATE
RACE.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT
JONATHAN HUNT REPORTS FROM
PHOENIX.
>> THE SPECTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOOMS LARGE IN
ARIZONA'S CRITICAL SENATE RACE.
>> I WILL STICK WITH HIM TO THE
END.
I AM NOT GOING TO DESERT HIM NO
MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
I WAS WITH HIM FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I WILL BE WITH HIM TO THE END.
>> FORMER MARICOPA COUNTY
SHERIFF JOE ARPAIO, RECIPIENT OF
TRUMP'S ONLY PRESIDENTIAL
PARDON, IS THE BEST KNOWN OF
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
>> THIS IS A STATEWIDE RACE WITH
NATIONAL CONSEQUENCES.
>> HE FACES STIFF COMPETITION
FROM CONGRESSWOMAN MARTHA
McSALLY, FORMER FIGHTER PILOT,
PREFERRED CANDIDATE OF THE
G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT.
>> WORKING WITH HIM TO SUPPORT
THE MILITARY, SECURE THE BORDER,
GROVER ECONOMY.
>> KELLY WORD, THE CONSERVATIVE
FAVORITE BEFORE SHERIFF JOE
DUBBED        JUMPED IN.
>> SEEKING OUT THOUGHTFUL,
CONSERVATIVE, INTELLIGENT
SOLUTIONS FOR PROBLEMS THAT ARE
FACING US.
I THINK THEY ARE ULTIMATELY
GOING TO BE THE ONES THAT GIVE
THE MOST IMPORTANT ENDORSEMENT.
>> RALLYING THE BIGGEST COULD --
IN A STATE TRADITIONALLY
REPUBLICAN, IT'S CHANGING
QUICKLY IN LARGE MEASURE BECAUSE
OF THE GROWING HISPANIC
POPULATION.
>> ARIZONA IS NOT A TIPPING
POINT POLITICALLY.
IT'S NOT THE SAME ARIZONA AS OUR
GRANDFATHERS AND GRANDPARENTS.
THE WINDS OF CHANGE ARE WITH US.
>> THE CONGRESSWOMAN WHO
DECLINED OUR REQUEST FOR AN
INTERVIEW IS THE LEADING
DEMOCRAT.
THERE'S A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
COUNCIL ON ISLAMIC RELATIONS.
SHE HOPES HER GRASSROOTS
CAMPAIGN WILL MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> I'M OUT OF THE FIELD, MEETING
WITH PEOPLE.
I AM AT EVENTS EVERY DAY.
I HAVE BEEN SINCE APRIL.
>> WHILE IT'S A SENSITIVE
SUBJECT, IT'S WORTH NOTING GIVEN
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN'S HEALTH
ISSUES, THERE'S ALWAYS THE
POSSIBILITY OF NOT JUST ONE BUT